[Music]
kim kardashian transforms into a
glamorous minion right now i think we're
going a little bit more we're like in a
glam phase yeah
watch out makeup by mario kim's got a
little artist in the making to thank for
her latest glam as daughter northwest
proves she's got some real talent
north gives her tick-tock followers a
step-by-step tutorial pulling out a
colorful eyeshadow palette and brush kit
to turn kim into a mommy minion inspired
by the hit animated film
of course north recently flexed her
makeup moves at her woodsy ninth
birthday party teaching her guests how
to do one of her specialties i got her a
teacher to show her and get all of the
supplies so
she wanted to teach her girlfriends and
we took about eight kids eight girls and
we went camping in the wilderness and
she wanted it to be really spooky and
she wanted
like these
mannequin heads and she taught everyone
there was a whole class that she taught
her friends how to do
special effects seems like north has
taken a real interest in special effects
makeup
[Music]
we've seen the mother-daughter duo
having a blast trying out fun
prosthetics on their joint tick tock
it's always so much fun
and north's solo work is pretty solid
too
meanwhile north's tool kit only seems to
expand kim told et she's been into
beauty since she was a toddler yeah she
really isn't to beauty she loves
she loves hair looks yeah that's her
thing and she loves a little bit of
makeup and
um she was always really cautious of me
wearing makeup because she loves to like
smother me and give me kisses but i if i
have makeup on she's not having it do
her makeup no
[Music]
well times have changed and seems like
north can't get enough glam time these
days she's really aware of makeup with
some professional training and
dedication we think north could have a
serious career if she wants to
[Music]